So the simple barrier operation doesn't work entirely.
And we look now at why it doesn't work.
Let's consider only two cores. Core 0, which we
will show in blue color what it's doing. And
core 1, which we will show in this
color what it's doing. What they're both doing initially
is doing something before they arrive to the barrier.
And let's say that Core 0 arrives here first.
So what Core 0 does, is resets release to 0, increments the count to 1, unlocks
the lock, checks whether the count is equal
to 2, and starts spinning, waiting for the
release to become 1. So now, release is still 0 because we just reset it. And
core 0 is going to to stay here spinning. So, what core 0 does is it essentially
does a load word of release, sees 0, and will check again. And it keeps
doing that. Now, let's see what happens
when core 1 arrives. Normally, what should happen
is, core 1 arrives, doesn't do this
because count is now 1. Increments the count,
exits the critical section. Sees that the count is equal to 2, resets the count,
sets the release to 1, and now core
1 proceeds past the barrier. What should happen
now is core 0 should see this release that we just set to 1. And also proceed
past the barrier. So, what should happen is really that we set the release to 1
here and core 0 sees that. Exits the
barrier and from then, everything will actually be correct.
But let's say that core 0 has been
checking the release, however, when the store happens, core
0 is delayed. For example, it's executing some sort
of an interrupt function so for a while it's
suspended in this place in the code and cannot
read the release fast enough. In that case, we
don't have this, and core 0 is still stuck
here. In a correct barrier implementation, core 0 will
eventually, at some point, it will return from the interrupt, read the release
that is 1, and proceed. However, what happens if core 0
is waiting here while core 1, after releasing and exiting the
barrier, does very little work and then comes back to the barrier
again? It sees that the count is 0, because it reset
it to 0 when it was releasing the barrier.
And sets the release to 1. And now it writes
0 to the release variable and now, even if core
0 checks the release here and sees what it is,
it's going to see the 0. So, core 0 is
going to proceed to wait here for a very long
time. Meanwhile, core 1 increments the count to 1. Checks
if it's equal to 2 for the second iteration of
the barrier. It's not 2, so core 1 is
now going to spin waiting for somebody to release
the second instance of the barrier while core 0
is going to be waiting there, in the first
instance of the barrier, and never being released. So
the only thing that can really core 1 now
is if core 0 somehow left and entered the
second instance of the barrier. The only thing that
can release core 0, however, is if somebody comes and releases here, but
that's not going to be core 2. So, now we have a deadlock situation.